Charles Darwin is one of the most
influential scientists of all time
Darwin's theory of evolution by natural
selection revolutionized science in the
19th century in 1831 Darwin joined a
global expedition of discovery as a
naturalist aboard HMS Beagle he spent
four years observing and comparing
animals and plants in many regions of
the world previously unknown to
scientists Darwin always said in a very
evocative sentence that the voyage of
the Beagle has been by far the most
important event in my life and it
determined my whole career he understood
what a transformative event that was
during his time on the Beagle
particularly in the Galapagos Darwin saw
animals that were different from animals
on the mainland and distinct to each
Island these startling observations
fueled the development of his
evolutionary theory in years to come so
what he came back with was a fabulous
research collection of the objects the
animals and plants and reflections on
their place in the natural world upon
his return Darwin began a prolific
correspondence with his scientific
colleagues around the world this
exchange of ideas was critically
important to the development of Darwin's
ideas Darwin had had a very large
influence in the United States he had
friends and acquaintances and
correspondence in the natural history
world
Darwin's research led him to contact one
of the Rising Stars of America's
scientific community James Dana who had
recently completed his own
circumnavigation of the globe during a
u.s. sponsored research voyage their
common backgrounds led to a detailed
correspondence on their own unique
observations about the natural world I
think we could really say that Dana was
the American Darwin Dana had the same
range of expertise a great knowledge of
the whole of the Natural History Kingdom
he had
the world in the same way as Darwin he
had spent his life collecting evidence
to explore the way that nature operated
he was considered probably the greatest
American geologist for most of the 19th
century he also developed certain ideas
that shows what tremendous insight he
had mutual interest in both the details
and the grand theories of science
connected the two men Darwin was anxious
to learn about the things that Dana had
collected and and had described because
it was a continuation of his own
interests as well and they both had of
all things of great interest in
barnacles the also had rested in corals
their surviving correspondence offers a
wonderful example of how Darwin worked
with the greatest minds of the day as he
developed his theory of evolution
ultimately Darwin published his ideas in
the Origin of Species
in 1859 a book that sent shockwaves
throughout the world there's never been
a book published before or after I think
that had the impact and the spread the
global spread since the Origin of
Species as the public and the scientific
world waved the meaning of evolution by
natural selection Darwin knew that
important gaps of evidence in the fossil
record would prevent some from accepting
his ideas among the first generation of
scientists to read and be influenced by
Darwin's ideas OC Marsh was motivated to
seek out fossils to test
Darwin's concepts OC Marsh who was the
creative director of the Peabody had
been in England in the early early 60s
and there he was a young zoologist
mineralogist geologists right in the
middle of this turmoil of Darwin's book
having come out after returning to the
United States Marsh unearthed and
assembled a comprehensive collection of
fossil horses which provided critical
evidence for intermediate forms between
ancestral and
species at the time of their discovery
they were immensely influential to
scientists and the public in ongoing
debates about the validity of
evolutionary ideas it was the first
major evolutionary transition spanning
something like 60 million years from a
little animal with four toes of the
front there was no bigger than a dog the
modern huge horse which only has one
finger in each foot nothing like this
had ever been discovered before a clear
series of evolution in the fossil record
now when Darwin wrote the Origin of
Species he was very dubious about what
the fossil record could ever tell
because in his view it would always be
to incompleted but here was the fossil
record of one kind of animal the horse
brilliantly documented and this was in a
way a tremendous vindication of Darwin's
theory Darwin's influence in America and
around the world persisted through the
19th century and continues today the
legacy left behind by the reactions of
his contemporaries offers a window into
the meaning of his ideas to those who
first encountered them and continues to
shape how they are interpreted today
you
you